die stimmen die vor künstliche
intelligenz waren werden immer lauter
jetzt hat sich ihre maske in einem
interview an die öffentlichkeit gewandt
und bringen das politisches handeln
gefordert
und er hat wirklich ziemlich
beängstigende perspektiven geschildert
ist also künstliche intelligenz eine
gefahr und was droht und von robotern
die über sie verfügen und wie sehen
die gefährlichsten entwicklungen in
diesem bereich aus jetzt sitzen herzlich
willkommen wer eigentlich ist es ganz
einfach 7 hawking beantworten kontakt
mit aliens eine überlegene rasse
könnte uns vernichten und unseren
planeten einnehmen vielleicht würden
sie sogar mit gutem recht tun um die
vernichtung der erde zu verhindern alien
wird also eine potenzielle gefahr wir
sind allerdings habe bei unserer eigenen
aliens zu bauen mit künstlicher
intelligenz ki konstruieren wir gerade
selbst eine überlegene rasse
was wird sie tun wenn die starken ist um
uns zu vernichten
ihnen macht hat jetzt in einem interview
auf der nationalen gouverneurs
versammlungen usa eindringlich vor
gewalt künstliche intelligenz ist ein
fundamentales risiko für die existenz
der menschlichen zivilisation so wie es
autounfälle flugzeugabstürze drohungen
oder schlechtes essen nie sein werden
ich habe zugang zu modernsten
künstlichen intelligenz die es gibt und
ich glaube die leute sollten besorgt
darüber seit ihnen max gehört zu den
pionieren der künstlichen intelligenz
und das lässt seine worte nochmal
bedeutungsvoller klingen macht gehört
zu den finanzierern von open-e einer
non-profit-organisation die erforscht
außerdem hatte das unternehmen die
meint finanziert das mit alpha go eine
software entwickelt hat die in der lage
war den besten spieler der welt zu
schlagen eine extrem komplexe aufgabe
inzwischen hat google die firma gekauft
bei der nationalversammlung hat er jetzt
vorweg ständig handelnden robotern
gewarnt die strafen runtergehen würden
und menschen töteten erstellen wir
jetzt für einen unternehmer eine
spektakuläre forderung auf künstliche
intelligenz ist einer der fälle wo wir
proaktiv regulieren sollten statt
reaktiv denn wenn wir bei der
künstlichen intelligenz reaktiv handeln
ist es zu spät
sprich maas fordert eine schnelle
regulierung von ki durch den staat wenn
wir zu spät gehandelt wird so seine
befürchtung könnte es bereits zu spät
sein zu sammeln könnt ihr tatsächlich
zu einer katastrophe führen
das war in der vergangenheit auch
schlecht aber es war kein risiko für
die existenz der zivilisation so macht
es ist nicht die erste warnung vor ki
markt selbst hat bereits vor drei jahren
der täter gewandt
er hält ki für eine größere gefahr
für die menschheit als atomwaffen auf
diesen hawking warnt bereits seit 2014
eindringlich vor
die entwicklung vollständiger
künstliche intelligenz könnte das ende
der menschheit bedeuten sagte er damals
in einem interview 2015 verfassten dann
unter anderem marketing und apple
mitbegründer steve wozniak einen
offenen brief in dem sie vor autonomen
waffen waren die in zukunft kriege
bringen könnten
ein wettrüsten militärischer ki waffen
ist eine schlechte idee und wollte
mittels ein verbot von autonomen waffen
die nicht um fakten von menschen
kontrolliert werden können untersagt
werden fordert nun die damals wie bitte
waffen mitteilten dass es wirklich keine
gute idee da würden wir nicht nur eine
überlegene rasse entwickeln sondern sie
auch noch mit den besten waffen
ausstatten
die forscher von die mine haben jetzt
letztes jahr zur beherrschung von ki
geforscht
zusammen mit der university of oxford
haben sie eine studie herausgebracht das
ergebnis kann muss mit einem tool suite
ausgestattet werden womit die sofort
gestoppt werden kann also einfach einem
ausschalter auch eu parlamentarier haben
das jetzt in einer resolution gefordert
in der revolution ging es um die haftung
bei von ki verursachten schäden
sie kann nur von menschen übernommen
werden wenn sie auch die volle kontrolle
haben es wird also noch viel über die
gefahren die chancen und entwicklung von
ki in zukunft zu hören geben und hier
bei pixum heiß ich euch natürlich auf
dem laufenden wenn ihr kein video zum
thema und auch zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollen dann sollten wir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit
bedroht künstliche intelligenz die
menschheit das da geht es um den sieg
von alpha go spannendes video natürlich
also nicht verpassen und ausblicken
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran